question. Um, Mark 8 verse 25. Christ
when he's healing the blind man, he does
a a twice action on his Sorry.
>> Yeah, twice.
>> Yeah, twice. Could you
>> Yeah. What's the reasoning for doing it
twice?
>> Yep.
>> It's ironic you bring up objection that
many Muslims bring up. Okay. Well,
>> I'm gonna use it against them.
>> Yeah. No, actually, they bring it up
saying, "Oh, look, Jesus can't be God
because he doesn't heal perfectly right
away." I mean, this is one side.
>> What is it?
>> No, I'm saying there's many examples
where that's not the case. So, that's
not really a good argument.
>> Well, that's what they say. They say,
look, when he went to heal him the first
time, he asked, "What do you see?"
>> Right?
>> He's talking about Mark 8:22 all the way
to 26. Why did it take Jesus two times
to heal the blind man? And they came to
Boseida and they brought a blind man to
Jesus and pleaded with him to touch him.
And taking the blind man by the hand, he
brought him out of the village and after
spitting on his eyes and laying his
hands on him, he was asking him, "Do you
see anything?" And he looked up and was
saying, "I see men, for I see them like
trees walking around." Then again he
said his he laid his hands on his eyes
and he looked intently and was restored
and began to see everything clearly. And
he sent him to his home saying, "Do not
even enter the village." Why did it take
the Lord Jesus two tries? Well, this is
an argument that people show say because
he's not God Almighty. He's just the
prophet messenger. And it may take him a
little more effort to get a miracle
done. Well, you can interpret it that
way if you want, but in the context,
what you have in the Gospels, it's not
just Mark, it's Matthew, Luke, and John.
You have what's called played out
parables
where Jesus will perform certain acts
that are parabolic in nature. Meaning
he'll do a miracle to point to a greater
spiritual truth. Almost like a miracle
that's enacting a parable. Like when he
curses the fig tree Mark 11. Why does he
curse the fig tree in Mark 11?
Because what does the fig tree
represent?
>> Is it a judgment?
Well, judgment on who?
>> On uh like judgment day.
>> Or is that not that connection? No,
>> no, it's a judgment on the temple
because it's the same context where he
goes into the temple and overthrows the
tables and the money changers
>> and cleanses it. Because in the Bible,
for example, in Luke 13:6-9, Israel is
called a fig tree. And so when he curses
the fig tree because it produces no
fruit, that's a sign that Israel, God's
fig tree, is barren and dead and it's
good for nothing but destruction.
Because when a tree is barren, what
purpose does it serve? Nothing. So what
do you do? You remove it. So the temple
representing God's presence among his
people is now spiritually dead because
the leaders are spiritually dead.
They're barren. So God's fig tree,
Israel, is useless. Good for nothing. So
what do you do with a tree? You cut it
down. So what did God do to Israel? He
destroyed Jerusalem and the temple.
>> I see. Yeah, that makes sense.
>> Yep. First Kings 10:14. Where's So why
is the Lord gradually healing the man's
eyes? Because notice the miracle follows
immediately after the second miraculous
feeding of the multitude. You guys
listening? This is stuff that's going to
come up by anti-trinarians who don't
believe Jesus is God. In Mark 8, Jesus
performs a second miraculous feeding of
4,000 men. Mark 6, 5,000. You guys know
this, right? If you go to Mark 6, Jesus
fed 5,000 men. But in Mark 8, he feeds
again a group of 4,000 men.
So, there are two miraculous feedings
mentioned by Matthew and Mark. It's in
Matthew 14 and Mark 15. Mark 15:32.
Two miraculous feedings. And the second
one, it says there were 4,000 men. How
many leftover fish and bread? And they
were satisfied. And they picked up seven
large baskets full of what was left
over, the broken pieces. So you guys got
it right. Two miraculous feedings.
Mark 6, 5,000 men. That didn't include
women and children. It was more than
5,000. Mark 8, second feeding of 4,000
men. and there are leftovers. So notice
two miraculous feedings. And yet even
though the I the apostles are witnesses
to these two miraculous feedings, they
still don't get it because they're
spiritually dull and spiritually unable
to see with their spiritual eyes.
Because how do we know this context says
this miracle
follows this right away? Let's start
from here. And the Pharisees came out
and began to argue
with him, seeking from him a sign from
heaven. Now notice he had just done a
sign right now. He did a sign. And this
was a second miraculous multiplication
of food and sign deeply in his spirit.
Notice he's grieved. He's you see even
the Lord there's only so much he can put
up with. And the Lord
reaches a point where he now becomes
disgusted with people and will now
rebuke them, chasen them, and no longer
entertain them.
So I don't think Jesus knew them. Well,
hold on. And sighing deeply in his
spirit, he said, "Why did this
generation seek a sign? Truly I say to
you, no sign will be given to this
generation." And leaving them, he again
embarked and went away to the other
side. Here, look what Jesus says.
Matthew gives you a little more extra
detail. And the Pharisees Saddies came
testing him. They asked him to show them
a sign from heaven. He write to them.
When it is evening, you say it will be
fair weather, for the sky is red. And in
the morning, there will be a storm
today, for the sky is red and
threatening. Do you know how to discern
the appearance of the sky, but cannot
discern the signs of the times? An evil
and adulterous generation eagerly seeks
for a sign, and a sign will not be given
it except the sign of Jonah. And he left
them and went away. This is the parallel
to Mark.
So, I'm trying to kill several birds
with one stone as I answer this young
man. So, when I go to Mark,
did Jesus get sick of them? Was he tired
of them? Was he fed up with them and
would no longer entertain them? Yeah.
And what did he do? Insult them. You
wicked, perverse, evil, adulterous
generation.
He sighed deeply in his spirit. So don't
you dare tell me it's not Christlike to
get fed up with people to cut off ties
with people to insult people ridicule
them and walk away. I don't think Jayth
in you. Now to your question
how many miraculous
multiplication of food took place by
this time in ma in Mark?
How many?
>> Okay. Now watch the disciples. He even
gets tired of them. He gets tired of
them.
And they had forgotten to bring take
bread
and did not have more than one loaf in
the boat with them. Now remember, they
just saw two miraculous feeding. Meaning
Jesus doesn't need your bread to feed
you. He just showed you you can do a
miracle. And he was giving orders to
them saying, "Watch out. Beware of the
leavenven of the Pharisees and leaven of
Herod." and again discuss with one
another the fact they have no bread. And
Jesus aware of this said to them,"Wh do
you discuss the fact that you have no
bread? Do you not perceive or
understand?" Notice the language of
seeing, perceiving.
I see your point. Do you not get it yet?
Do you have a hardened heart having eyes
that do not see? There you go.
Do you not see? You see how everything
is masterfully placed where it's at by
design of the Holy Spirit.
>> It's not a coincidence the miracle of
the blind man takes place right after he
says, "You don't perceive. You don't
see. You don't get it.
>> You have eyes, but you can't see. And
having ears, do you not hear? And do you
not remember when I broke the five
loaves for the 5,000? How many baskets
full of broken pieces you picked up? The
first miracle they said to him 12. When
I broke broke the seven for 4,000, how
many large baskets full of broken pieces
did you pick up? And they said to him,
seven. Even the leftovers are symbolic.
12. The 12 tribes of Israel. Who feeds
the 12 tribes of Israel? Jesus their
God. Seven. The number of rest. Who
gives Israel rest? Jesus Christ. You see
how deep it goes?
>> Yeah.
That's really good. You understand how
your Bible is so deep. It's miraculous.
When you unpack, you're like, "Man,
truly this is from God." Notice again
for everyone. He's getting it. And I'm
getting you to the point for everyone.
Notice the depth, the beauty, the
miraculous structure of your Bible. The
first miracle, 12 baskets of bread.
Well, bread is a staple.
If you guys are not aware, before the
altar
right outside the first curtain, the
second curtain, they had the bread of
the presence. 12
pieces of bread that was on the altar,
right? 12 plates of bread. 12 that was
called the bread of the presence, the
bread of the face. Why 12? Because of
Israel. Why bread? Because it's telling
you your staple, your sustenance comes
from the face of God. The showbread, the
bread of presence. How many basketics of
bread? 12. Why 12? Israel. But who
provides and feeds Israel? Jesus, the
God of Israel, because he's the face of
God. But then the second miracle, seven.
Why seven? Jesus gives people rest.
And if you're hungry and starving, you
won't rest. If you're sick and ill, you
won't rest. So he heals you and
nourishes you so you can rest in his
presence. All right? So he says, and he
was saying to them, do you not
understand?
What are you talking about? You don't
get it. You don't understand.
So it's about spiritual sight, right?
>> Yeah. That's really good. I did not I
did not even know that that was
connected. That's
>> So why twice? Now watch again,
masterful. If you come looking for
understanding because you believe, God
will give you understanding. If you come
to oppose the scriptures, then God will
hand you over desires and you're going
to find mistakes everywhere. Now the
miracle after he told them, "Man, you
have eyes you don't see. You don't
perceive. You don't get it. Twice I
multiplied bread and you're wondering
about bread.
Don't you understand the bigger picture?
I'm not talking about bread. I'm talking
about the teaching of the Pharisees and
Herod because it's like levan. It will
spread and corrupt you.
Levan spreads. Don't embrace their
teaching because it will spread and
corrupt the body of Christ. And that's
in 1 Corinthians 5:6 to8. Remove the
leaven from among you. Meaning
wickedness and false teaching. Now the
miracle. Let me break down the miracle.
You guys are enjoying it. Come on. Give
me feedback you guys. He's he's getting
it. Doing it for you guys. Let me know
you're not bored.
And they came to Boseida and they
brought a blind man to Jesus and pleaded
with him to touch him. And taking the
blind man by the hand, he brought him
out of the village. And after spitting
on his eyes and laying his hands on him,
he was asking him, "Do you see
anything?" And he looked up and was
saying, "I see men for see them like
trees walking around." Now, even this
points to something. Now, let me show
you how deep it's going to get. Then
again he laid his hands on his eyes and
he looked intently and was restored and
began to see everything clearly. And he
sent him to his house saying, "Do not
even enter the village." Now notice the
second time he didn't ask him, right?
>> No, he didn't.
>> Why didn't he ask him? Do you now see?
>> I mean, he he knows he doesn't need to
ask him.
>> So that means he deliberately
didn't heal him instantly.
>> Mhm. He deliberately
hastened the healing because he wants to
tr teach you something.
Just like the disciples, their eyes are
slowly opening and they're slowly
perceiving a slow process. This man is
slowly
seeing clearly. It's meant to mimic the
dullness and the slowness of heart of
the disciples in getting Jesus's point.
number one. But number two, notice that
the Lord wants him to see men as trees.
Why? Because the Bible says,
"You must be a tree that produces good
fruit. If not, you'll be cut down and
destroyed." Here, nothing coincidental.
Everything is deliberately designed.
All right,
you ready?
Watch here.
Everything is there deliberately. Why
did the Lord slowly open his eyes? Two
reasons. To show the slow, gradual
illumination of the disciples because
they're not getting it. Two miracles and
they still don't see clearly. Secondly,
it's meant to show that humans are to be
vibrant trees producing righteous fruit.
If not, they'll be cut down and
destroyed. Here it is. Matthew 12 33
to34. Either make the tree good and its
fruit good or make the tree bad and its
fruit bad for the tree is known by its
fruit. There you go. Why did he see men
as trees? Because Jesus is saying you're
a tree. Either you're going to be
planted in living waters and produce
good fruit or you're going to wither and
be destroyed because you're dead. Like
the fig tree.
That's good. That's really good.
>> How can you being evil speak what is
good? For the mouth speaks of that out
of that which fills the heart. Still not
convinced. Matthew 7:15 to 23. Well to
to 20. Beware of the false prophets
who come to you in sheep's clothing but
inwardly are ravenous wolves. You'll
know them by their fruits. Are grapes
gathered from thorns, bushes, or figs
from thistles? Even so, every good tree
bears good fruit, but the bad tree bears
bad fruit. A good tree cannot bear bad
fruit, nor can a bad tree bear good
fruit. Every tree that does not bear
good fruit, it's cut down and thrown
into the fire. So then you will know
them by their fruits.
Jeremiah 17:es 5-7.
Are you guys blown away by the
extraordinary miraculous structure of
your Bible? Everything ties in. Thus
says Yahweh, cursed is a man who trusts
in mankind and makes flesh his strength.
I was supposed to put verse eight.
Sorry. See, supposed to have verse eight
here. Sorry about that. Watch here.
Flesh his strength.
So if you trust in human beings to
support you, you're cursed because
they're double-minded, fickle, and
disappoint you. He will be like a
juniper in the desert. He will not see
when prosperity comes, but will dwell in
stony waste in the wilderness, a land of
salt which is not inhabited. Blessed is
a man who trusts in Yahweh, whose trust
is Yahweh. He'll be like a tree planted
by the water.
Okay? That sends forth its roots by a
stream and will not fear when the heat
comes, but its leaves will be green and
will not be anxious in a year of
drought, nor refrain from yielding
fruit. So men are trees. How about here?
Psalm 1. How blessed is a man who does
not walk in the counsel of the wicked,
nor stand in the way of sinners, nor sit
in the seat of koffers, but his delight
is in the law of Yahweh. And his law he
meditates in light. And he'll be like a
tree firmly planted by streams of water.
Now what are the waters? the Holy Spirit
which yields its fruit in its season and
its leaf does not wither and whatever he
does he prospers. The wicked are not so
but they are like the chav which the
wind drives away. Therefore the wicked
will not rise in the judgment nor
sinners in the congregation of the
righteous. For Yahweh knows the way of
the righteous but the way the wicked
will perish. So you are a tree planted
by streams of water. Right? Okay. I'll
let you ask your other question, but I
just want to see by water, right?
>> What is the water?
>> The spirit.
>> Say it again.
>> You said the spirit.
>> Well, where do I get that? Because
remember, tell me, hey, prove it. Don't
just take my word for it. So, I want
proof because you look like a bald
handsome deceiver.
Okay. What's the waters? The Holy
Spirit. Oh, Yahweh, the hope of Israel.
All who forsake you will be put to
shame. Those who turn away on earth will
be written down because they have
forsaken the fountain of living water.
Even Yahweh, that's the same chapter,
Jeremiah 17. So here, Yahweh is the
fountain of living water, right?
>> Mhm.
>> John 7 through 8:39. Proving the Holy
Spirit is Yahweh God. That's why we're
trinitarian. If Yahweh is the fountain
of living water, but here we're told the
Holy Spirit is, that means the Holy
Spirit is Yahweh. John 7:38-39, he who
believes in me, as the scripture said,
from his innermost being will flow
rivers of living water. But this he
spoke of the spirit. So the Holy Spirit
is Yahweh, the fountain of living
waters, whom those who believed in him
were going to receive. For the spirit
was not yet given because Jesus was not
yet glorified.
So now, do you understand why the
gradual process?
>> Yeah, that's that's amazing.
Now you see why he says, "What do you
see? I see men trees." Because the Lord
was showing us that we are trees that
need to be planted in the Holy Spirit in
order to be fruitful and dwell forever.
Any other questions?
>> No, Sam, that's amazing. Glory to God.
Thank you. Appreciate that.
>> Good, man. God bless you, brother.